[Music]
I'm really glad to see you all here I
hope you enjoyed the first today as much
as with it I'm here on the stage with my
friends Ignacio who is engineering
manager on Google Google kubernetes
engine my name is Jesse for a church and
we're gonna talk in them or a lot of
fancy stuff but before we do let's take
a little survey
can you please all stand up for just a
little while
excellent thank you all right so those
of you who use horizontal fold
autoscaler on custom metrics you may sit
down all right I see a few faces all
right ok next question is for those of
you who never had problems figuring out
the pots back you may sit down ok good
good all right
those of you who use not auto-update in
production even see you may sit down
right those of you who believe that you
should all use cluster autoscaler in
production you may sit down thank you
okay that was great that was fun thank
you very much
so here is the contract in the next 45
to 50 minutes we are going to tell you
how to become a hero by setting up a
pool of
auto-scaling workers based on the pop
sub-q and then we are going to tell you
how to not to be defeated by wrong falls
back using vertical pole autoscaler who
takes care of it for you
then we'll explain how vertical
polluters gala will never get defeated
by missing resources in the cluster
because the cluster take care of it
takes takes care of itself due to
cluster autoscaler and note of the
provisioning and then at the end
remember man in black with this little
device will tell you well you can really
forget about the infrastructure part
because it just works so you can focus
on the top part ok so here's the deal
let's get started
before we get started right everybody is
talking about auto scaling these days
this is important think and you should
expect for all of your workouts to scale
right scaling is different for your
front ends for your webpage for the
mobile front ends and it's different
when you talk about databases or file
systems but because kubernetes was built
with scalability in place and because
gke is the best
Hostel version of kubernetes you should
have super high expectations about
what's happening alright so before we go
there a quick recap what's happening at
kubernetes kubernetes is very simple
right cobranet is in kubernetes you have
a pulse back and the pulse effect you're
saying well here's my docker container i
want this many replicas of it and well
this is the amount of resources i want
to use right once you have it you give
the config file true kubernetes master
you put the container image through the
repository and then kubernetes master is
consulting a scheduler and saying oh
your scheduler could you please tell me
where is the best place I can deploy
this very pod right so scheduler is
looking at the lower layer on the
picture we're all the nodes you're
located and saying here and then
kubernetes download support from the
repository and deploys its on the
cluster and it's then it's maintaining
its through its life right so whatever
happens with the port it will get
restored by kubernetes as guys watching
it right it's always gonna be there for
you now as you saw on this picture we
are in fact talking about more than one
layer right you have the infrastructure
layer on the bottom where your virtual
machines or your physical machines or we
call them nodes in kubernetes and then
you have the workload layer and this is
the fancy layer this is the abstraction
layer where everything is beautiful and
you just deploy your bolts and we expect
you to just have fun of the poet
deploying your balls without worrying
about the lower point so because of that
and because of this two layers you in
fact have also more than one dimension
of auto scaling right so in the upper
layer well you start from horizontal pod
auto scaling
right you have the pods and in case of
the workloads that you can load balanced
in any way like your mobile front-end or
your website well if there is more
traffic you need more pods if there is
less traffic you should need less foam
right
and also scaler does it for you and this
works well but not always right because
in some cases you actually need to
change the pod requests you may wanna
say I won't double the amount of
processor or triple the amount of memory
right and that's the vertical scaling of
it that's a totally different dimension
well and that was the that was the
workload layer defensively now
realistically then you have this other
layer and it's different between the own
premises and the cloud on-premises well
if you have what you have
so that's your thumb cost and the best
you can do is to use them all ideally
just use a hundred percent of CPU
utilization on them and be done right
nobody ever achieved that but it's like
use them right in the cloud you don't
have to do that in the cloud in fact you
have the ability to request exactly what
you need and then use it only when you
need it
right and this goes a long way like you
may request specific types of machines
that or having the amount of memory and
the number of course that exactly
correspond to what you want deploy on
top of it you may want to request
something that it's been more
sophisticated but has because it has a
graphics accelerator all of that is
possible in the cloud not so much and
without any flexibility on-premises so
now well on the infrastructure layer in
the cloud
you also have abilities to scale right
this goes roughly the same way meaning
well if there are more workloads
deployed from the workload layer then
you're going to need more nodes in in
the infrastructure layer to handle it so
the idea here is to reactively very
quickly get you to appropriate type of a
node right and remove them as soon as
they're not needed and now so so this is
something I'll call a cluster autoscaler
so autoscaler number three in this story
and then there's one more piece and this
one more piece I'm very proud of this in
alpha and it's coming together hopefully
later this summer it's called no total
provisioning and it's getting a
different type of nodes depending on
what you need and you don't need to
really worry about it so we are going to
talk piece by piece about all of these
four dimensions giving you a great demos
my friend is resting here in the corner
but he'll be up to speed in a second so
all right so here in the story we have
four dimensions of auto scaling HP a as
we call it horizontal photo scaler more
faults based on the utilization matrix
vertical photo scaler different pole
sizes right amount
Plus autoscaler more nodes based on
pending faults in its scheduler and then
note of the provisioning all the goodies
there are different node fools and the
overall scheduling optimizer this is
what we're going to talk about so let's
talk about horizontal pole - scaling in
practice so this is this is an example
of a workload that is load balance
imagine we have four ports on the left
and what you see on the right is is
their CPU utilization Express in terms
of how much the port is using versus
what was requested okay so as you can
see this bolts are running hot right but
if you manage to add one more point and
the load balancer that you using can
spread the workload across more ports
and through this the average utilization
will be lower and the same story will
happen if you go to the other direction
imagine you you were at the stage like
this or all of the ports were running
below 50% of CPU utilization now women
say well we're we're heating up the data
center right 50% of our cores are
basically doing nothing right so in the
ideal case we would just remove one of
these boats and get the load denser on
the other phone so so pretty much this
all's all comes to a target right
instead of targeting say I want my
workload to roll to run on average
across all posterity fold around
something like this which is maybe like
60% say and the autoscaler is getting
the workload to that state right it's
adding more pods when needed it's
removing them we're not yet observing or
all of the laws of your cluster as they
are so that was the situation where you
have the state proportional to the
number of requests but it's not always
the case and that's why we have
something I would call custom metrics in
the situation of custom metrics UK you
may extract any metrics from your system
and this can be number of requests per
second
this can be latency server system this
can finally be something like backlog of
Dusk's in the task queue which we have
here right so imagine there's a very
simple queue we use pops up to you
because we are Google but you may use
any other cube can be RabbitMQ it can be
whatever zookeeper right and then you
have producers that believer at piece of
data to be processed and register this
fact in the queue that's a message right
and then you have workers that pick up
this message and start to process it and
then at the end you have autoscaler and
what the autoscaler is doing is making
sure that there is enough workers to get
this data process in a timely manner
that's how it works super powerful your
tens and tens of customers that we
talked to that just need a system like
that in order to process their workloads
in a like timely manner in a very
controlled way so let's get started I'm
going voyage
agnostic illogic to the stage to walk
you through the first part
I can switch to the other one and thank
you for great introduction to Auto
scanning in gke
so it's gonna be my pleasure today to
demonstrate how all these dimensions of
auto scaling actually work in GK I'm
going to start with in the first part of
my demo with setting up the horizontal
potato scaler for the pool of workers
that will be consuming tasks from a
message queue these are going beat three
simple steps first of all we're gonna
set up the workers the task queue the
second step will be configuring the
autoscaler that based on the size of the
or the number of elements in the queue
will auto scale the workers and finally
we'll add some tasks into the queue and
just to see this is the system rolling
all right but before I get started let
me show you the environment we are we
are using here so so basically what
cluster I'm using
so as you can see um there's a quite
funny name of the cluster but it's
actually a development cluster so that I
can show you some of the cool features
of VP and cost are two scalars are not
launched yet all right let's take a
little bit closer look at the cluster so
I'm going to check what notes do I have
here
so my cluster is actually running five
notes each of them being and one start
at one VM sin GCE okay
so I've got my cluster so the next thing
is the workload I actually set up my
worker pool before this presentation has
started as well and through a deployment
controller so the department is called
worker now let's take a look at the
definition of this of this department so
the important thing is we've got two
repeaters so we start with two worker
tasks all these talks will have the
label up worker assigned and you may
also notice that because finding the
right path back is so difficult I just
didn't set any request from my memory so
going back to the console so next thing
once we have the workers let's check out
our message queue so as user motion
we're using called pops up so we've got
one topic defined which the producers
will be using to publish tasks into the
message queue and we have one
subscription that is called worker
subscription that's letting the
consumers consume messages from the
worker taskkill our setup is such that
each worker task is consuming messages
from a single subscription so therefore
what we're modeling is effectively a
task where each task in the queue will
be delivered to exactly one worker all
right so now the next step once you have
worker queue now horizontal autoscaler
so let me create control autoscaler
my in directory yeah all right so let's
take a look at again at the definition
of this horizontal autoscaler sorry yeah
this is alive when you see I didn't pray
to demon gods that were possibly thank
you all right so back to the definition
of our horizontal pod autoscaler so the
interesting bit here is that we are
using number of pending messages in our
cube as a scaling metric this is an
external matrix is supported in the v2
version of v2 API of horizontal path
autoscaler now the target average value
what does it mean that means that we
want to have on average 25 messages in
our cube for every pot replica in our
deployment so roughly it means we want
one worker consuming processing the task
for every 25 task in the queue and as
you can see we're also obviously
pointing our horizontal potahto scaler
at the worker deployment down here all
right so now let's take a closer look at
this horizontal pada autoscaler
in keeps using cube cuddle so the
horizontal Square has been successfully
created the name of the HPA is Q scalar
now the interesting column that I want
to drag your attention to is the targets
column so this is this is where we're
actually the target metric is
represented so the value 0 means that
currently we have 0 0 messages in a
queue for every worker in the
in our deployment while the target value
is 25 the reason why horizontal Palacio
scalar is not scaling down our
deployment is that actually we have set
up the minimum and maximum number of
project leaders for our deployment and
the minimum number is two so we are kind
of staying with which two replicas here
alright with that we're moving to the
third step which is let's add some
messages into the queue to see things
rolling so I have a little script that
will be added tasks and I'm going to
show you how the script actually looks
like I can have a super simple thing
so this basically generates 100 messages
into our worker tasks topic and doing so
with 10 prophets then messages in each
so this seems to be pretty simple
mechanism but actually the cool thing is
that it is a very powerful design
pattern in fact last year on the next
2017 we showcased together with Airbus
their solution where they were
processing satellite images exactly with
this approach so what they've been doing
is they've been publishing the images to
be transcoded into the message queue and
then they were running a horizontally
scaled pool of workers that were
processing this this task and obviously
horizontal autoscaler was managed to
find a good trade-off between you know
the performance of the system and cost
so in the meantime I hope my message is
good at it okay and then let's see what
horizontal autoscaler has to say about
it now alright so what we see is that
the metric is to 0 which means our
horizontal pod autoscaler did not pick
up yet did not pick up the new metric
from the from the from the cloud pub/sub
it quite yet so we can okay it's growing
it's 25 now so it's it's picking up but
basically the thing is that what what is
happening right now horizontal a lot of
scaling is
is getting new updates from cloud
pub/sub within magic being number of
messages in the queue so in the meantime
I hope that the our deployment has
already been auto scaled so alright
still we have only two so let's take a
look at hard horizontal Pilates color
again still 25 slow delivery of matrix
we have to wait a little bit maybe I can
take some questions in the meantime sure
yes is any better awesome
25 all right any more questions then
okay so I propose that we while we're
waiting for this one let's talk about
what can go wrong with this story it's a
good idea and in the meantime we'll see
what happens sure yeah so let's switch
back to slides for a second so provided
this is actually firing out 50 wait
shoot or demo goats up we're at a so
maybe that's why well if this worked it
was all good right now could anything go
wrong okay back please back to the demos
line alright so we trying trying we got
50 so this is the the value that was
expecting you to see right we generated
100 messages and we have two workers so
the average per worker is 50 while the
target was 25 so again let's take a look
at our deployment then and the
deployment is the controller that runs
my worker tasks and voila so right now
we have four worker tasks deployed so
all right works okay thank you
yeah getting around it up loud alright
so back to this lights plate
so yes besides demo goats nothing else
can go wrong huh
well not buy it we've been actually
serving you for a reason right well
realistically how many of you run a very
detailed performance test every time you
deploy a new near deployment okay one
two three all right
and how many deployments do typically do
per day in kubernetes oh oh yeah I'm
assuming a lot and in that case this may
get problematic if all of the sudden the
situation changes in your port and you
do not correct it in the bots back so
imagine in this situation we're
obviously setting up for that to
demonstrate imagine in this situation we
started to run out of memory because the
very last built at the just one more
feature and this one more feature is
using for more memory than before
nothing is wrong with it it's just a
mismatch between the kind of a virtual
space which is your container which was
requested at the certain size and what
you really need so in that situation
you'd go out of memory and if you go out
of memory what's gonna happen your job
it's gonna get evicted by kubernetes
right and then scheduler will see it and
because I I promise the kubernetes will
always take care of your thoughts
they'll get recreated and after a while
they will get evicted and so on right
well there is another possibility there
is in fact a race condition because UNIX
is also very small so you you may in
fact get your application reset by white
Linux before it gets evicted but in
either case you're going to get in this
vicious cycle of not having a workload
running so with that in mind we build
vertical fold auto scaling the vertical
pole autoscaler is it's a piece of
beauty it's that's rough that's roughly
this it looks at your at your workload
deciced here they whatever we have in
the 95% and the remaining five this was
your fault let's say this was your fault
Express in the CPU utilization and now
vertical coil to scaler is saying hahaha
you know just request a bigger machine
for that so you get a bigger machine and
all of a sudden you're not running 90%
of the utilization of that space you're
running seven thing is word is saved so
now how do we do this right we do it in
a very simple way through three steps
right if first one is vertical pole
autoscaler is watching the utilization
doesn't do it for every port you have no
you actually have to turn it on and you
have to tell us or will tell vertical
pole autoscaler what is the label right
what what pose do you want to watch once
you do this vertical pole to scaler is
consulting the metric server and it's
calculating the recommendation and that
minimum is just providing the
recommendation and then also you can
enable automatic update mode and I'll
talk about in a second you can in fact
actuate right but at minimum this so
simple spec well assume for a while that
you actually put the request for memory
on CPU well and it was wrong right for
some reason so what what vertical
photosphere is doing is consulting
metrics server it looks at the piece on
the Left which is your spec and on the
right it's outputting very simple
recommendation and this recommendation
is in the middle it says target and it
says well CPU true cores memory a
certain amount right and then is also
providing a range and the range is for
the updater to either take action or not
take action if you're not outside of the
wrench there is probably no reason for
you to update even if the target is
somewhere in between so that's how it
works right so now we have two modes of
update if you choose to use it right one
is only happening at the time of
creating of the new port
so whenever Newport gets created
vertical Peduto scalar is reading what's
in the falls back is also comparing it
with the recommendation and if that's
wrong or if if there is a mismatch
outside of the
safety wrench then it applies correction
so in fact the boat that's going to get
deployed has a correct request it
doesn't mean that the post wreck was
corrected it's just all vertical polo to
scale your knows better and does it
right and then there is a second mode
that we call full auto that week by the
way can I use here in a second that does
it also for all running Falls right in
fact it's observing the pulses report
disruption budget it is taking Falls one
by one draining dam and recreating or
forcing to get recreated so that they
can just get adjusted so that's that's
it and you may ask I probably already
spoil it but you may ask really straight
together so the answer is yes and the
answer is also wall however don't try it
with the horizontal
auto-scaling running on cpu utilization
because this is the same metrics it's
not working quite yet so on everything
else we promise it's working and with
this back to Ignasi to demonstrate thank
you Jersey alright so in this part of
the demo I'm going to use a vertical
pole autoscaler
and as you remember I was quite naive I
didn't set any memory requests for my
application and it makes me a little bit
anxious you know I deployed it and I
kind of hope it runs so so I will
investigate the memory consumption of my
application and then I'll use vertical
product of scaler to actually check
whether I was right or whether the
system is you know running well and then
I'm finally I'm actually going to become
fiend convinced by the VP
recommendations and I will turn on the
automated actuation a particular
autoscale recommendation ok so let's go
to see what's happening in production so
I'm going to start driver and I have a
little dashboard here which presents me
the memory consumption of my worker
tasks
deployment
doesn't look good really so what is
happening here
all these worker tasks are basically
growing the memory consumption quite
fast up to some point and then they are
kind of disappearing so so this is
wearing me so I'm gonna to take a look
at my pots so let's go you skip cuddle
again well so yes I've got a couple of
them running but then I have also a
bunch of them evicted so so indeed like
something someone's killing my pots
I've seen them growing to like roughly
around like 2.5 gigs of memory
consumption as far as a member from this
new driver dashboard so I'm gonna check
my notes how much memory actually the
notes have so the reason is I'm checking
it is that if I don't set memory
requests I'm pretty much free to use
most of the available memory or
resources on the notes most of it
kubernetes would take care that there is
some extra margin all right so on I have
this little command line that I'm gonna
be typing here which basically using
cube Catalan numerating my notes again
but this time I also want to check
what's the amount of allocated boo
memory on these notes all right so they
have 2.7 gigs of RAM
these n1 start at one VMs have 2.7 gigs
of allocatable memory to user pots so
this is close to what I was observing on
a stock driver okay so I have my
suspicions already that basically my
pods need more memory so okay so with
that let's try to consult vertical Cole
autoscaler so right now I'm creating a
vertical pole autoscaler again
all right and it's being created now we
switch the presentation to show you in
bigger letters was being done so I have
created a vertical pod autoscaler and
the interesting bits of these
configurations are first of all matching
by labels so vertical pod scatter is
different than horizontal pod o scalar
it doesn't point you W don't point V PA
at specific controllers such as the
point or replica set instead is that
with more flexible and you can select
specific parts that you want the vpa to
generate recommendation for through a
label query in this case is up worker
now the next important piece of
configuration here is the update policy
so in this case I set the update mode to
off because I want to know is like I
want to see BPA's recommendations and
well I'm hoping that this will give me
some more clues about what's what's
going on in the system as a reminder you
know like we can also set up the update
mode to auto so with in which case the
vertical pole autoscaler
would do the rowing update of all my
pots that are matching the label query
and recreating them basically killing
them and letting and letting and letting
them be scheduled again with the new
resource requests the reason is that
currently in kubernetes there is no
functionality there's no capability of
adjusting the resource requests no
limits for running pots so so you
basically have to kill them and let them
be rescheduled again by the scheduler
with the newest requests alright so in
the meantime let's see if our VP a has
generated any good recommendations for
us
all right it did actually so so there is
this in VP a resource which is a
customer service definition we've got
this recommendation section where we see
that our VP a says hang these worker
tasks should be probably running at a
target of 3.5 gigs of ram memory request
so this is totally not something that
that my infrastructure is prepared for
my notes were 2.6 gigs so I'm going to
be very very naive now I don't want to
deal with the infrastructure I just I
just want to actuate vertical photo
scalar decision so what I'm gonna do is
I'm going to edit this VP a and I'm
going to change only one parameter which
is the update mode so I'm changing to
Auto boom and let's see what will happen
in the meantime I'm hanging over to
Jersey all right so let's go back to
slides so now we're gonna let the magic
happen in the meantime let's talk about
the proper magic so in this section
we're going to talk about the cluster
auto scaling obviously you may expect
what would happen the normal situation
right we would have the automation that
we set up the vertical pod autoscaler to
attempt killing the pods and then we
would attempt to recreate them with the
different pod requests the pod requires
would have been the memory requests
would have been something around 3.2 I
remember right so there would be ending
so we would literally kill our setup
forever until somebody on the operator
site on your dev up site would have
realized or something is wrong we cannot
dis or not schedule so luckily it's just
not how it's working Oh
we told you you can forget about the
infrastructure because the
infrastructure is not forgetting about
you so this is exactly what's happening
here right Oh glass roto scalar works
true observing the pod requests and
based on this requests making a decision
or suggestion so what you have here is a
scheduler right the scheduler is in a
normal situation it's looking at the
pods request and it's placing a note
right so if there is enough resources on
a note
sorry it's playing the boat if there is
enough resources on a node to to deploy
a boat it's simply happening right but
there may be situation if there is not
enough resources and you necessarily
need to add one note ring like this well
there is an operation involved right
what is this triggered by this is
triggered by depending Potts nothing
else right no utilization of any kind
the reaction is true like well do I need
more or in some cases it may be in a
situation like this which is even more
annoying because now you have too many
too many note it looks like doing the
notes so in the ideal case you would
have done some kind of a diffract eclis
move one of the poles somewhere else so
that you can remove the note and have a
better utilisation and kind of better
price to performance as you may say so
this is all done by the cluster
autoscaler cluster autoscaler
is doing literally two functions right
and within each of those other three so
it was just depending Potts first of all
it's it's just seeing what the scheduler
would be seeing and the pending pod
means there is no space in the
infrastructure for the pod to be
scheduled right and then it simulate the
scheduler by trying to look into what
would have happened if I are the
one or two or three nodes right with the
deployment actually land and what would
be all of the poles be scheduled if
that's the case again yes cluster auto
schedule triggers adding notes this is
done by by the part of the
infrastructure but the decision comes
from a classroom to scale now in the
same time it also watches the
utilization but it only watches it for
the contraction of the cluster so if any
node is running below some set
utilization right now I believe we we
have it set to 50% this is a trigger to
look around for for the trigger for
customer schedule look around and make
some checks right what would have happen
if we deleted that machine would all
pods be rescheduled or are they an
assistant notes running there and there
will be a big disruption right
how would that play with the pod
disruption budget if if it's possible
the decision comes to drain and delete a
note and then the scheduler is
rescheduling the the poet step that
we're running there somewhere else and
through this we have a better package
system so that was a very intro to but
the real cluster autoscaler looks
something like that because in a cluster
you don't just have one type of nodes
what you could but in most cases you are
deploying more than one type of the
workload mond more than one size of the
falls and it's very hard unless you
manage to deploy super big nodes that
can accommodate everything and you don't
care for the empty space running on them
it's very super hard to optimize it with
just one type of nodes that's why the
good practice that we were suggesting
and was there for like at least last
year maybe year and a half was true used
in node fools
not pools or groups of identical notes
within the cluster like example like
this one is like we you have some small
notes some medium and some weak and true
this is the cluster autoscaler does a
little bit different job right
it is it is monitoring the state of all
of the entire cluster but it's also like
whenever there is a pending fault it's
actually simulating the action of
scheduled or across all of the node
fools so like what would that have been
if we enlarged one of this or the other
one or the other one right well this is
a very simple example when you look at
this single port right but the poles are
coming in all the time and they they
have of their of different sizes so
realistically there is lots of
interesting combinatoric coming in but
thanks to this you end up getting a very
well and tight package cluster so so
when at the recommendation is placed
then the new node is add that in the
node pool over choosing by the cluster
autoscaler and then the pod gets
deployed now there may be a situation
similar to what we are setting our demo
for right that despite the fact that we
already have three types of node post
three sizes of not fools we now arrive
with the port that wouldn't feed to a
notice and before November late November
last year that would be the moment where
your system would have get stuck right
and it will have to wait for someone to
notice there is a problem
luckily and this feature is now in alpha
and it's coming to a better later this
summer we have no total provisioning
which is like a consent consultant to
the cluster autoscaler so plus root of
scare is not only ran
the simulation looking at all three of
this node Falls in fact is it's
consulting notes auto provisioning
saying what what if there was another
one and if there was what would be the
size and then at the end it decides
there is a new node for mediate if
through each one and then the pod gets
deployed now throughout this talk we are
telling you you can forget about not
provisioning so we just explaining it to
you so that you see how simple it is but
we leave you very little control just
like you are switching a cluster
autoscaler
simply on and off and you also get us a
budget the minimum and the maximum of of
RAM of CPU you just enable auto
provisioning you don't need to worry
about this layer this layer just does
the job for your higher layer the higher
layer is where your workload is so you
better know what's happening this one
it's just at the adjusting to get you
the best gospel performance so ok so
that's roughly it so let me just walk
you through what just happened and then
we're gonna have a look into the demo
again so we had a horizontal photo
scaler set to look at the pub sub-q as a
parameter and auto scale so that for
every 25 tasks there was at least one
worker deployed we had a vertical pod
autoscaler
she watch like after we enabled it into
the auto mode now it's watching if there
is everything right with the requests of
resources and if not we actually set it
to auto and as a result whenever the the
request is wrong it will get adjusted
and then on the infrastructure layer the
cluster autoscaler is observing the
unscheduled vaults and it's actually
consulting with the VBA so that this
process doesn't happen prematurely in
awkward way we don't want all the pots
to be killed for
and then be pending later so in fact
there is there is a loopback in which
there is a translation of like are these
resources already prepared and only if
they or the updates happening and most
of the real-life cases don't happen that
drastically right they happen every once
in a while and then they know total
provisioning is a consultant to the
class roto scaler it's making it more
optimal so as you can see you have 402
scaler but in fact you have one system
that is auto scaling all of it for you
by having all four layers talking in
unison so that's what we have and now
are we ready yeah all right all right
thanks Daisy so it's a final step of our
demo so so we're gonna see what happens
so remember like I was playing on the
weed pot out of scatters horizontal pot
autoscaler and vertical potahto scatter
and thankfully I got my cluster set up
with the smart no doubt the provisioning
and cost autoscaler enabled so that I
did not care about my notes at all so
now let's see what happened so I'm going
back to the console and I have my little
script that prints the pots but also
prints the you show it to you actually
but also prints the memory requests of
those pots so remember like when I set
up the pots back for my deployment the
memory limits were empty so let's see
what they are now so again we have all
these evicted pots that we had before
but we also have for running pots and
all these pots have actually the memory
requests set to three point five five
gigs which was the recommendation of
vertical product of scatter so this
works and they are running how is it
possible given that I had five nodes
with 2.7 gigs each so let's take a look
at the notes I'm using
before we go there historical data that
we are showing there is like all of the
failed notes but you look at the for
that ironic we requested for to be
running in there for
so indeed we have our original five 5v5
notes in the default node pool but we
also have a new and one standard two VMs
in a new node pool created automatically
by no other provisioner and these guys
are running five gigs of ram each and
thanks to that our worker tasks get
scheduled SolidWorks lets me take a look
at final at the stock driver charge
refresh it and let's see if it looks
better indeed we see that the workers
grow to bigger memory usage than before
they were allowed to and they are
stabilizing they are running at this at
this level so Wow
[Applause]
okay so let's go back to slides this was
this was great so we hope you you see
that you can really forget about not
provisioning well in fact you can set it
up and almost observe that it
occasionally goes to zero or almost to
zero because there are still some system
level dolls that needs to be running and
only or are dead when you need it so you
may wonder is that all it should be all
because we have one more minutes and
then questions but well one more thing
well wouldn't it be great if that also
worked with the graphics accelerators
well it does with the new release that's
coming together soon note of the
provisioning will be capable of
scheduling your nose with the graphics
accelerators so now imagine this very
precious resource that is super
expensive get super automatically
provisioned only when you need it so you
deploy your pod you pod requests just
has one extra line and it says what type
of graphics card I want right and true
the four steps that we were describing
in fact three because the horizontal
focus carrier doesn't need to be part of
it you just get it and then whenever
it's not needed it will be removed
so in fact you yeah while ago you saw
there were four new nodes and then we're
also still before all the old nodes
they're going to get removed there is a
cycle loop that's running every ten
minutes
so like in a while like we've been
speaking for in short time and a while
they will get removed because this is
how it works all right so I'm just like
just and you can also imagine the
direction where it's going is that
doesn't have to be on the size of the
nodes and on the GPUs but like whatever
infrastructure requirements of your
workload so you basically the idea is
you specify declaratively D requests the
requirements from the infrastructure in
your pot specs or in your
controllers and that's it you don't have
to care about the infrastructure the
right infrastructure will be provisioned
for your boy no doubt the provisioning
alright so that's all now we have a
couple of minutes for questions and then
we'll be outside to take more questions
[Music]